I actually went on the web and looked at
you on The Cosby Show like you're there
with Theo in the crowd and it's a small
role but at the time it probably seems
like the biggest start in the world did
your family start to really go wow he's
really making it in this business I my
mother always thought I was fine my
father was the guy who'd say if you
don't make it by 23. yeah I want you to
I want you to work for me or isn't sure
he thought I would sell insurance or
it's something he knew my brother my
brother's four years older than me right
and he kind of knew my brother would
take care of me somehow he didn't know
what my brother was going to do but how
did you get that job when you were at
NYU how did you get the job on The Cosby
Show Anthony Quinn's son Lorenzo yeah he
was in my acting class I was very
friendly with Lorenzo and he and Anthony
Quinn and Cosby were buddies and so
Lorenzo said just out of nowhere I'm
gonna get pop to talk to Bill Cosby to
see you do stand up wow and and he
didn't see me the cast he sent the
casting director down Barry Moss who's
ended up being my man manager for a
while and a very nice guy and he brought
me in and somehow the uh I was Goofy
enough they wrote me a goofy part and
that's a big break right I mean that was
like the number one show in the world it
was a giant thing and suddenly you're on
there and here's a story I heard when
you were on The Cosby Show yeah because
Chris Rock idolized to Bill Cosby so
much you would bring him down with you
too we used to hang out there to hang
out he he was crazy Rock though even
then
he he got somehow I was doing the show
he got to warm up the crowd right the
the usual warm-up guy right didn't you
tell you this no I'm I know about it oh
you do okay he didn't show up right
right and because he's hanging out with
you they say hey you're a comedian warm
up the crowd right did you hear what he
did go ahead he he
he gets a couple of giant laughs and I'm
like oh boy the cause is gonna see Rock
Hill and he he was like 19 or something
20 years old and you're like wow Rock's
about to be discovered and he'll be out
and take over my jig man right and then
come move bringing him down yeah yeah no
I was happy for the kid but but he um he
just says
something about Bill Cosby and the place
of Applause and he says something like
create I don't know something like the
most racist character of all time is
Mushmouth
and the crowd even the crowd was kind of
like what the [ __ ] you're in the cause
where are you going with this but he he
had balls his whole career so he's in
kaza's house he says that Cosby has
created the most racist character I
don't remember what went on after that
but I remember kind of icy feeling and
people being mad that I brought him yeah
all of a sudden the blowback is on you a
little bit you're like oh Rock what did
you do did you did you pull him aside
listen I got a small gig here what are
you doing I don't I think even Rock's
eyes were in a day's afternoon what did
I do exactly
foreign